Take 2 for cameras.
拿2个相机。
I'm sorry.
对不起。
I've seen let's go to them all about a thousand times and you sure are not in it.
我已经看过一千遍了，你肯定不在其中。
I was in the other one There's another video Welcome to sand castles in the sand.
我在另一个视频中有另一个视频欢迎来到沙子里的沙堡。
So let's go over our strip really quick, and then we'll go over Sand castles are like a metaphor, you know this video they're a metaphor for a relationship That was beautiful Took a lot of time to build and Just like that The water came along and just washed it away and it was gone Just that quick Welcome welcome to another episode of how we made your mother I'm Joshua Adam here with my friend Craig Thomas.
所以让我们快速回顾一下我们的地带，然后我们回顾一下沙堡就像一个隐喻，你知道这个视频它们是一段关系的隐喻那是美丽的花了很多时间来建立就像那样水来了，只是把它冲走了然后就消失了就这么快欢迎欢迎来到我们如何造就你母亲的另一集我是约书亚·亚当和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Hey Craig Alec.
嘿克雷格·亚历克。
That was great.
那很棒。
We of course just saw that or heard that for the first time.
我们当然只是第一次看到或听到。
Thanks for putting that together.
感谢您将其放在一起。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
We have quite a bit of sand castles in the sand behind the scenes material that you all can go see.
我们有很多沙堡的幕后材料，大家可以去看看。
It's going to be popping up on your Instagram and your TikTok all week.
整个星期它都会出现在你的 Instagram 和 TikTok 上。
And you know, it's so funny seeing you know, Chris Lefontane and Michael Shea and Pam and and Kobe and that shoot, like, you always feel like you're in the present, but you're always in some archival footage.
你知道，看到你知道的克里斯·莱方坦、迈克尔·谢、帕姆和科比，以及那次拍摄，你总是感觉自己身处当下，但你总是在一些档案镜头中，这真是太有趣了。
We're all living in archival footage, essentially.
本质上，我们都生活在档案录像中。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
It's all good as well.
一切也都很好。
Show is that.
秀就是这样。
We're eating an old and from another era.
我们吃的是另一个时代的古老食物。
It doesn't feel that long ago, but everybody looked real young in those.
感觉不是很久以前的事，但每个人都穿着那些看起来很年轻。
I know, I know, what a fun thing to see.
我知道，我知道，这是多么有趣的事情啊。
Thanks for putting that together, Alex.
谢谢你把这些放在一起，亚历克斯。
So of course today we're talking about the episode sandcastles in the sand.
所以今天我们当然要讨论的是《沙子里的沙堡》这一集。
What, Alec?
什么，亚历克？
You look upset, Alec.
你看起来很沮丧，亚历克。
Oh, sorry.
哦，抱歉。
I didn't do my job.
我没有做好我的工作。
I don't know when it came out.
我不知道什么时候出来的。
So just keep talking.
所以就继续说吧。
Well, yeah, you played it totally cool and nobody noticed at all.
嗯，是的，你表现得很酷，根本没有人注意到。
I've never seen a look of horror on a person's face, but like a tunish panic.
我从来没有见过一个人脸上露出惊恐的表情，而是像惊慌失措一样。
I was sure I said something that was untoward.
我确信我说了一些令人不快的话。
Yeah.
是的。
So this episode who wrote this episode, Craig, maybe you know the answer to this since Ali.
所以这一集的作者，克雷格，也许你自从阿里以来就知道这个问题的答案。
This is Courtney Kang.
这是考特尼·康。
She wrote most of her all of the Robin Sparkles episodes, I believe.
我相信，罗宾·斯帕克斯的大部分剧集都是她写的。
But I don't.
但我不这么认为。
I don't know the date.
我不知道日期。
And Alec has has mostly failed us.
亚历克基本上让我们失望了。
He's failed us on the date.
他在约会时让我们失望了。
No, he did it.
不，他做到了。
He's rescuing it from the flames.
他正在把它从火焰中救出来。
No, it came out on April 21st, 2008, my son who had not been born for four more years is birthday.
这不，它出来的时候是2008年4月21日，我已经四年多没出生的儿子生日了。
Okay.
好的。
Well, that's a really special thing we get to celebrate with you, that particular landmark.
嗯，这是一件非常特别的事情，我们要和你们一起庆祝，那个特殊的里程碑。
I couldn't, how did Courtney end up with the Robin Sparkles episodes?
我不能，考特尼是怎么结束罗宾·斯帕克斯的剧集的？
Was that just, she was just enthusiastic about the movie?
难道她只是对这部电影感兴趣吗？
Yeah, I mean, she just loved it.
是的，我的意思是，她只是喜欢它。
She just, she, she comes from that world of like, she loved all of those singers.
她只是，她，她来自那个世界，她喜欢所有这些歌手。
You know, she just, she, her hand shot up.
你知道，她只是，她，她举起了手。
Like when this, when this idea came up, it was, Courtney was like, I was in Pennsylvania in the 1990s.
就像当这个想法出现时，考特尼就说，我在 20 世纪 90 年代在宾夕法尼亚州。
I was all about Tiffany.
我满脑子都是蒂芙尼。
I was all about Debbie Gibson.
我只关心黛比·吉布森。
I was all about Sheila Paula Abdul.
我只关心希拉·保拉·阿卜杜勒。
Sheila, all of these folks, and she was just like, this is my world.
希拉，所有这些人，她就像，这就是我的世界。
Please put me in, coach.
请让我加入吧，教练。
Yeah.
是的。
But Carter and I wrote the songs.
但是卡特和我写了这些歌曲。
We wrote the Robin Sparkles songs.
我们写了罗宾·斯帕克斯的歌曲。
And obviously it's a big group effort, but I really feel like Courtney had a great, a great beat on the tone of like, not only the Robin Sparkles stuff, but also all of this really dramatic, like the revertical of it all.
显然，这是一个巨大的团队努力，但我真的觉得考特尼的基调非常非常好，不仅是罗宾·斯帕克斯的东西，而且所有这些都非常戏剧性，就像这一切的逆转一样。
Like Courtney was very much able to channel her inner teenage girl in the 1990s, which really helps the time.
就像 Courtney 在 20 世纪 90 年代非常能够展现她内心的少女气息一样，这对那个时代确实很有帮助。
And I say that might only complain about this episode, and this is from a Ted Back to One.
我说这可能只是抱怨这一集，而这是来自《Ted Back to One》。
Reverda goes a great name, and I don't understand why Ted does like it.
雷韦尔达（Reverda）是一个很棒的名字，我不明白为什么特德（Ted）喜欢它。
I know.
我知道。
That name.
那个名字。
Either you can't do better than Reverda go, and he keeps saying it's not a good name, and maybe if it could be a great title for this episode.
要么你不能比 Reverda 做得更好，他一直说这不是一个好名字，也许它可以成为这一集的一个很棒的标题。
But, and doesn't offer up a better name either.
但是，也没有提供更好的名字。
I feel like Ted would have liked that name, and that we have, I don't know what we just, Ted needs a little runner.
我觉得特德会喜欢这个名字，而且我们有，我不知道我们只是，特德需要一个小跑步者。
We'll just make him, I feel like we'd failed to explain the premise there a little bit.
我们就让他来吧，我觉得我们没能解释清楚那里的前提。
I feel like Ted should have been, and this is what I would rewrite Ted's saying, because I thought about the same exact thing, Josh.
我觉得特德应该是这样，这就是我要重写特德的话，因为我想到了同样的事情，乔什。
I would have Ted now say if we could do this again, like Marshall calls, if Ted comes up with the observation and the theory, Marshall names it reverted to go, and Ted's like, this should have been the take.
我现在会让泰德说，如果我们能再做一次，就像马歇尔呼吁的那样，如果泰德提出了观察结果和理论，马歇尔将其命名为“恢复”，而泰德则认为，这应该是这样的。
Oh no, you're not gonna just stamp a cute little name.
哦不，你不会只盖上一个可爱的小名字。
Granted, that's a good name, but you're not just gonna stamp that name on it and then take credit for the idea.
诚然，这是一个好名字，但你不能只是在上面盖上这个名字，然后就将这个想法归功于自己。
And then history will forget that it was my observation, just cause you came up with the catchy little name.
然后历史就会忘记这是我的观察，只是因为你想出了这个朗朗上口的小名字。
That would have been a better and more specific tick.
那将是一个更好、更具体的标记。
Don't you think?
你不觉得吗？
That was my regret.
那是我的遗憾。
I was like, Revertego is pretty good.
我当时想，Revertego 相当不错。
It's a great name.
这是一个伟大的名字。
Can't be Revertego.
不可能是Revertego。
And I was like, had appreciates a good, you know, moniker or whatever.
我当时想，很欣赏一个好的，你知道的，绰号什么的。
Like I completely agree.
就像我完全同意一样。
I mean, it's offered up no reason that he doesn't like it other than he just doesn't.
我的意思是，除了他不喜欢之外，没有任何理由表明他不喜欢它。
I found myself wondering why he doesn't like it.
我发现自己想知道为什么他不喜欢它。
Like this many years later, like, why didn't we explain this?
很多年后，我们为什么不解释一下呢？
And it was like, I think that's why.
我想这就是原因。
I think that's why Ted doesn't like it because Marshall's gonna get all the credit.
我想这就是特德不喜欢它的原因，因为马歇尔会获得所有的荣誉。
I think Ted and Marshall didn't have that much to do in this episode and we were kind of the Greek chorus.
我认为特德和马歇尔在这一集中没有太多事情要做，我们就像希腊合唱团一样。
You were, you were.
你曾经是，你曾经是。
And we just wanted a little thing, but I think we didn't really think through the little thing to make it fully logical and hold water.
我们只是想要一件小事，但我认为我们并没有真正考虑到这件小事，使其完全合乎逻辑并站得住脚。
So just give, we've jumped ahead a little bit, but give our listeners a little armchair summary of what this episode is.
所以，我们已经提前了一点，但请给我们的听众一个关于这一集内容的简短总结。
Yeah, I mean, the really thumbnail is Rob and Sparkles part two, y'all.
是的，我的意思是，真正的缩略图是《罗伯和斯帕克尔斯》第二部分，你们大家。
But the longer version is, this idea of a vertigo, this idea of someone from your past comes back around, in this case, Robin's ex Simon, from the time she was, Robin Sparkles, as a teenager in Canada in the 90s.
但更长的版本是，这种眩晕的想法，这种关于你过去的某个人的想法又回来了，在这个例子中，罗宾的前任西蒙，从她还是罗宾·斯帕克尔斯的时候开始，她是 90 年代加拿大的一个青少年。
Someone comes back from your past, and all of a sudden, you become that version of yourself, again, you start to remember who that person was, it starts to infect you a little bit, it just comes out of you, and then we kind of go person by person and explore different iterations of, everyone has a Ted has punchy, who really has like, I'm a Brooklyn like diva on the stoop kind of attitude from growing up in Brooklyn in the 1990s.
有人从你的过去回来了，突然之间，你又变成了那个版本的自己，你开始记起那个人是谁，它开始一点一点地感染你，它就从你身上流露出来，然后我们一个一个地去探索不同的迭代，每个人都有特德的强力，他真的有类似的，我是一个像布鲁克林一样的女主角，从 20 世纪 90 年代在布鲁克林长大的那种态度。
We sort of go through and show, not everybody.
我们只是经历并展示，而不是每个人。
It's almost a shame we didn't get to like, Marshall's 90s here because Marshall has, we got some good glimpses of Marshall in the 90s at other moments, but that idea of that person from your past who brings this past self out and maybe there's good aspects of that and maybe there's really bad aspects and this idea that Robin is completely blinded to this guy who's been mistreating her since her teenage who's played so wonderfully by the great James Vanderbeek.
遗憾的是，我们没有喜欢这里的马歇尔90年代，因为马歇尔喜欢，我们在其他时刻看到了90年代的马歇尔，但那个来自你过去的人的想法将过去的自己带了出来，也许有好的方面，也许有真正糟糕的方面，而且罗宾对这个从她十几岁起就一直虐待她的人完全视而不见，而伟大的詹姆斯扮演了如此出色的角色范德贝克。
I love him in this episode so much.
我非常喜欢这一集中的他。
Yeah, it's, I want to talk a lot about James.
是的，我想谈论很多关于詹姆斯的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
Nice to spend some time with him.
很高兴能和他一起度过一段时间。
You know what?
你知道吗？
Totally.
完全。
He's so funny, he's so, so funny in this episode.
他太有趣了，他在这一集中非常非常有趣。
But just on the idea of the central idea, you know that we revert back to ours, or there are certain people that are so provocative from our past that they rewind our psyche decades.
但仅仅就中心思想而言，你就知道我们会回到我们的时代，或者有些人对我们的过去如此具有挑衅性，以至于他们让我们的心灵倒回了几十年。
Yeah.
是的。
And I have, you know, there were two.
我有，你知道，有两个。
This is my question.
这是我的问题。
I was gonna say, who is this in your life?
我想说，你生命中的这个人是谁？
There was a girl that I was like pretty, just it completely enamored over in eighth grade and one like my freshman and sophomore year of high school, like very formative young years.
有一个我很喜欢的女孩，只是在八年级时就完全迷恋上了，还有一个像我高中一年级和二年级的女孩，就像非常成长的年轻岁月。
And I see these women now who have husbands and children and they are lovely people, solid citizens, like, you know, they are out in the world doing their thing.
我现在看到这些女人都有丈夫和孩子，她们是可爱的人，坚定的公民，就像，你知道，她们在外面的世界做自己的事情。
And when I see them, I still get a little.
当我看到他们的时候，我还是有一点感触。
Oh...
哦...
You know.
你知道。
I mean, all in one in particular, the one from eighth grade for some reason, I cannot shake the feeling of being like Kevin Arnold to win over around her.
我的意思是，尤其是其中一个，出于某种原因来自八年级的那个，我无法摆脱像凯文·阿诺德那样赢得她的支持的感觉。
Like she's perfect reference.
就像她是完美的参考一样。
Kind of makes you weak in the knees and I don't.
有点让你膝盖发软，但我不会。
How about Winnie Cooper herself on our show?
温妮·库珀本人在我们的节目中怎么样？
That's like the killer.
这就像凶手一样。
It was every guy, it was our age, it was like, hi, Danica.
这是每个人，这是我们这个年纪，就像，嗨，丹妮卡。
But I do think it's such a smart idea.
但我确实认为这是一个非常聪明的想法。
It also reminded me of something I read about birth order.
这也让我想起了我读过的一些关于出生顺序的事情。
You know, they say that, you know, older children are this way and builders are this way, younger children are this way.
你知道，他们说，你知道，大一点的孩子是这样，建筑工人是这样，小一点的孩子也是这样。
And they've done studies and someone should look this up and see if this is now outdated because this is a couple of years ago, but the idea is it doesn't carry into the outside world.
他们已经做了研究，应该有人查一下，看看现在是否已经过时，因为这是几年前的事，但想法是它不会传播到外面的世界。
It's not like you're an older child or middle child in the world, but when you get back in that family system, or that, you revert.
这不像你是世界上的大孩子或中间孩子，但当你回到那个家庭系统时，你就会回归。
Absolutely, yeah, yeah.
绝对是的，是的，是的。
I feel like we should have had a family version of this.
我觉得我们应该有一个家庭版本。
And this is me rewriting the episode 18 years later.
这是 18 年后我重写的情节。
I'm like, we should have had a family because that is a very powerful one.
我想，我们应该有一个家庭，因为那是一个非常强大的家庭。
But I will say I just had one of my oldest friends in the world, my oldest friend in the world, Mark Fitchman lived down the block for me.
但我要说的是，我有我在世界上最古老的朋友之一，我在世界上最古老的朋友，马克·菲奇曼（Mark Fitchman）就住在我的街区。
He just visited me for a few days.
他刚刚来看我几天。
And I was laughing in a way and doing like bits in a way that was so, like, I only have with him.
我以某种方式大笑，以某种方式做一些事情，就像我只和他在一起一样。
We've known each other since we're two years old.
我们从两岁起就认识了。
He listens to this, hi Mark.
他听着这个，嗨，马克。
It was lovely having him visit.
他来访真是太好了。
And my wife and even my kids were like, you're just back there with Mark doing stupid bits.
我的妻子，甚至我的孩子们都说，你只是在后面和马克一起做一些愚蠢的事情。
You guys are 10 years old again or 15 years old again.
你们又回到了10岁，或者又回到了15岁。
There's something, you know, some brings out something in a great way.
你知道，有些东西能以一种很好的方式带出一些东西。
That's the absolute best version of that.
这绝对是最好的版本。
but there's negative versions of this too, where we refer and we do not like that, I like that version of myself with Mark because we're very creative and funny and very joyful, but there's stuff that you might not like to revisit.
但也有负面的版本，我们提到但我们不喜欢那样，我喜欢我和马克的那个版本，因为我们非常有创意、有趣、非常快乐，但有些东西你可能不喜欢重温。
My friend Dionne Flynn, who I went to grad school with, we have a word game that we developed like in the late 90s that we still play to this day, but there's something about, and my wife noticed it immediately, she's like, she notices that my sense of humor is so much goofier and more playful around him.
我和我一起读研究生的朋友迪翁·弗林（Dionne Flynn），我们有一个文字游戏，是我们在 90 年代末开发的，直到今天我们还在玩，但有一些东西，我的妻子立即注意到了这一点，她就像，她注意到我的幽默感在他身边变得更加愚蠢和有趣。
Like he questions a goofy playful button in me that people push.
就像他质疑我体内一个被人们按下的傻乎乎、好玩的按钮。
And I also find I'm like, my synapses fire a little quicker when I'm around him.
我还发现，当我在他身边时，我的突触会放电得更快一些。
And I enjoy that feeling.
我很享受这种感觉。
And conversely, there are certain people that for whatever reason feel a little heavy and that it's hard to be light-hearted and funny around them for whatever reason, or we're gonna get into our whole dynamic right now and we're just supposed to be having fun talking about.
相反，有些人无论出于什么原因感到有点沉重，并且无论出于什么原因在他们周围都很难轻松有趣，或者我们现在就要进入我们的整个动态，我们只是应该开心地谈论。
idea.
主意。
I said I was gonna name names.
我说我要命名。
I tell this.
我告诉这个。
You're pointing at me as you say this for those of you who can't see the video.
当你为那些看不到视频的人说这句话时，你是在指着我。
Some people in the top right square.
有些人在右上角的广场上。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Yeah, I think it's a really provocative idea.
是的，我认为这是一个非常具有挑衅性的想法。
It's not just romantic, but it's friends, you know, I mean, like high school friends who I'm still really close with, like, you do find yourself, you know, your kind of high school head gets screwed back on.
这不仅仅是浪漫，而且是朋友，你知道，我的意思是，就像我仍然非常亲密的高中朋友，就像，你确实发现自己，你知道，你那种高中头脑又被搞砸了。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
It's wild.
它很狂野。
Yeah.
是的。
It's wild.
它很狂野。
It's very real.
这是非常真实的。
When you're young in that age, you're so unformed, you're looking for some identity to glom on to you.
当你在那个年纪还年轻的时候，你是如此的不成熟，你正在寻找一些身份来迷惑你。
That's it.
就是这样。
This is who I am.
这就是我。
the people you admire, like they look cool, they look like they know who they are, they look like they, you know, they have confidence in their taste.
你钦佩的人，他们看起来很酷，他们看起来知道自己是谁，他们看起来对自己的品味有信心。
Confidence.
信心。
They, you know, like my older sister Melanie, she did synchronize swimming, you know?
他们，你知道，就像我姐姐梅兰妮一样，她也做过花样游泳，你知道吗？
And synchronize swimming friends were these like incredibly cool Catholic school girls, you know?
花样游泳的朋友们是非常酷的天主教学校女孩，你知道吗？
They were like kind of like bad, but they were like, went to Catholic school.
他们有点像坏人，但他们就像，去了天主教学校。
And my sister went to her Jewish day school.
我姐姐去了她的犹太走读学校。
Yeah.
是的。
like she wanted to be like a Catholic school like bad girl you know for like a little part that was who was her radar for what was cool you know yeah a hundred percent yeah yeah I think it's I think it's so real it's such a needy moment in your life and I like I really loved how Kobe played that side of her coming back out and just how absolutely pathetic she is around Simon it's really like moving and poignant in a way it's like heartbreaking watching her when he dumps her in the flashback in the van.
就像她想成为一个天主教学校一样的坏女孩，你知道，就像一个小角色，谁是她的雷达，你知道什么是酷的，是的，百分百是的，是的，我认为这是如此真实，这是你生命中如此需要的时刻，我喜欢我真的很喜欢科比在她回来时扮演的那一面，以及她在西蒙身边是多么可悲，这真的很令人感动和心酸，当他把她扔进闪回时，看着她就像令人心碎。货车。
And she's, he's saying, it's because Louise Marsh's parents have put in a pool, he just wants to go hang out in this other girls pool.
他说，她是因为路易丝·马什的父母建了一个游泳池，他只是想在另一个女孩的游泳池里闲逛。
And Kobe's like, we've got a sprinkler on my front lawn, run right through it.
科比说，我们家门前的草坪上有一个洒水器，你可以直接跑过去。
And she sort of near tears.
她几乎要流泪了。
Yeah, she's so funny in that sequence.
是的，她在那个序列中很有趣。
She's this is a great Kobe episode.
这是科比精彩的一集。
We should know my favorite moments from this episode, for sure.
当然，我们应该知道这一集中我最喜欢的时刻。
But actually, one of my favorite, like, Kobe just pure laughs is is Simon's entrance into the bar as modern day.
但实际上，我最喜欢的之一，比如科比纯粹的笑声是西蒙像现代一样进入酒吧。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And that's all kind of clocking.
这就是所有的计时。
Like this guy doesn't look great.
看来这个人长得不怎么样啊。
And cutting to her and her like, oh my God.
然后切到她和她的样子，天哪。
He's like that laugh.
他就是这样笑的。
She does.
她做到了。
The laugh is so funny.
笑起来真是太好笑了。
She is so in the pocket in this episode.
在这一集里，她真是太有钱了。
She is just hitting home run after home run.
她刚刚打出一个又一个的本垒打。
I believe it's one of her favorite episodes right, Alec.
我相信这是她最喜欢的剧集之一，亚历克。
Very sorry we're sure you all wish that Kobe could join us.
非常抱歉，我们确信你们都希望科比能够加入我们。
And we really wished we could, she could too.
我们真的希望我们可以，她也可以。
We reached out.
我们伸出手来。
she's very busy right now, but Kobe's going to join us through the magic of video.
她现在很忙，但科比将通过视频的魔力加入我们。
Here we go.
开始了。
Well, well, well, it's Sam Castles in the Sam time.
好吧，好吧，好吧，这是山姆时代的萨姆·卡斯尔斯。
I was asked to talk about some of my memories from that episode.
我被要求谈谈我对那一集的一些记忆。
The first one that comes to mind is we got to go on a little field trip, which was so cool.
我想到的第一个想法是我们要去一次小小的实地考察，这太酷了。
We shot mostly on stage and this time we got to drive up north to Malibu to Zuma Beach, I believe, which is quite a famous location.
我们主要在舞台上拍摄，这次我们必须开车向北到马里布到祖玛海滩，我相信，这是一个相当著名的地点。
And it was just such a fun magical day.
这真是一个有趣而神奇的一天。
You know, this is our second video and let's go to the mall was really just me me out there dancing by myself and some amazing backup dancers.
你知道，这是我们的第二个视频，我们去商场吧，真的只有我自己和一些很棒的伴舞在外面跳舞。
But St.
但是圣。
Gels was in the sand, had some pretty incredible guest stars.
凝胶在沙滩上，有一些非常令人难以置信的客串明星。
Alan Thicke, Tiffany, which was like a merging of dreams come true where it was just kind of unbelievable that she came and she did the video.
艾伦·锡克（Alan Thicke）、蒂芙尼（Tiffany），这就像梦想成真一样，她来了并制作了视频，真是令人难以置信。
And then James Vanderbeek, who did such an incredible job and spent the day with us on the beach, just being silly and making each other laugh and making out in really awkward ways.
然后是詹姆斯·范德贝克（James Vanderbeek），他做了一件令人难以置信的工作，和我们一起在海滩上度过了一天，只是很傻，让彼此开怀大笑，并以非常尴尬的方式亲热。
It was a really fun, magical day and again, another experience I never anticipated doing on the show, and I'm really grateful for it.
这是非常有趣、神奇的一天，也是我在节目中从未预料到的另一种体验，我真的很感激。
So thank you for making me go down memory lane and thinking about that episode again, because it was really one of my favorite ones.
所以谢谢你让我回忆起那一集，因为它确实是我最喜欢的一集。
Love you all.
爱你们大家。
Love you guys.
爱你们。
Thanks, Cubs.
谢谢，小熊们。
Yeah, that was awesome.
是的，那太棒了。
It makes so much sense that she loved this one.
她喜欢这个是很有意义的。
She loved being Robin Sparkle.
她喜欢成为罗宾·斯帕克尔。
She just like, she inhabited that character so wonderfully, the idea that to do a part two and it was the ballad she was like all over that it was not like the uh it's like a superhero alter ego but some sort of reversion well a river to go river to go yeah there's certain things that i think are that like there i i would say there are certain things on how i made mother that i got asked to do that felt like not fun humiliation and then there's other things that are like so fun humiliation there's different flavors of humiliation yeah there's different flavors of it and Robin Rose for Kobe was like the most fun kind of humiliation because it's yeah, you know, it's it's like looking back.
她只是喜欢，她非常完美地演绎了这个角色，这个想法是要拍第二部分，这是她喜欢的民谣，它不像呃，它就像一个超级英雄的另一个自我，而是某种回归，一条河去河去，是的，有些事情我认为就是那样，我会说，有一些关于我如何成为母亲的事情，我被要求做，感觉不是羞辱，然后还有其他事情就像这样有趣的羞辱有不同的风格，是的，有不同的风格，科比的罗宾·罗斯就像是最有趣的羞辱，因为是的，你知道，这就像回顾过去。
I don't know.
我不知道。
It's almost like a slide show of your former self, like where you you see your fashion choices and you see yourself and you go, oh, that was so ridiculous.
这几乎就像是你以前的自己的幻灯片，就像你看到你的时尚选择，你看到你自己，然后你就会，哦，那太荒谬了。
We thought that was so cool.
我们认为这太酷了。
Those suspenders or whatever, you know, absolutely.
那些背带什么的，你知道的，绝对的。
It's and I do want to give a shout out to Alan thick and Tiffany like just that was so cool that they came and did that video shoot I'm heartbroken because I had to go back for I think it was a wedding like one of my best friends was getting married and I Missed that beat shoot.
我确实想向艾伦·厚特和蒂芙尼大声喊叫，他们来拍摄视频真是太酷了，我心碎了，因为我不得不回去，因为我认为这是一场婚礼，就像我最好的朋友之一要结婚一样，我错过了那次拍摄。
I think Chris Harris and Courtney covered it for me So Alec made this wonderful making of that that makes me feel like I was there for the DVD set at the time For that season and Alec worked on the show and we and I it's one of my greatest regrets Is that I wasn't there for that shoot because Carter and I wrote that song we were so invested And I just couldn't we did it was it was like a special location shoot day during like an off week We had on the Korean production actually and I had to fly back to New York And just watching even clips of that and make me like ah, I can't believe I wasn't there for that one But it's it came out so great Um, but it's wistful, right?
我想克里斯·哈里斯和考特尼为我翻唱了这首歌，所以亚历克做了这个美妙的制作，让我觉得我当时就在现场观看 DVD 那个季节，亚历克参与了演出，我们和我这是我最大的遗憾之一是我没有参加那次拍摄，因为卡特和我写了那首歌，我们非常投入，但我就是不能这么做，因为这就像一个特殊的外景拍摄日，在一个休息周我们实际上在韩国制作，我不得不飞回纽约，只是看了那个片段，就让我觉得啊，我不敢相信我没有在那场，但它的结果是如此伟大，嗯，但它很渴望，对吧？
I mean james van der beek and allen thick we've lost both of them I know since that time and it's just that moment.
我的意思是詹姆斯·范德贝克和艾伦·厚特，我知道从那时起我们就失去了他们两个，而这就是那一刻。
I don't know obviously this is not Anything prophetic, but it was so So there's that moment where like James just like disappears in the video.
我不知道这显然不是预言，但确实如此 所以有那么一刻，像詹姆斯一样消失在视频中。
Yes, that has become achingly poignant, that exact moment.
是的，那一刻已经变得令人心酸。
Yeah.
是的。
I know what you mean.
我知道你的意思。
It's supposed to be so silly and cheesy in the video and now it could break your heart.
视频中的内容本来应该是那么愚蠢和俗气，但现在它可能会让你心碎。
I know.
我知道。
Yeah.
是的。
He was such a good dude.
他真是个好人。
He was so funny in this episode.
他在这一集中非常有趣。
He was so kind and open and very like willing, talk about the sort of like good humiliation.
他是如此的善良和开放，非常愿意谈论那种好的羞辱。
He was very willing to be like, I love playing against this type.
他非常愿意说，我喜欢和这种类型的球员比赛。
I'm this really handsome guy.
我真是个帅哥啊
Make me balding, make me have a punch, make me be smuggling beers in my pants.
让我秃头，让我打拳，让我在裤子里走私啤酒。
Yeah.
是的。
You got to play with his own image.
你必须玩弄他自己的形象。
I mean, I talked about it a little bit, you know, on set like just playing an iconic character and being, I think like the feeling of being trapped as especially a teenage heart frog is a really tough gig.
我的意思是，我在片场谈过一点，就像扮演一个标志性角色一样，我认为被困的感觉，特别是青少年心蛙是一个非常艰难的演出。
Totally.
完全。
And I think that he, in some ways you guys were riffing on his heart throbness by saying, yeah, okay, this was the guy in high school that she was like in love with.
我认为他，在某种程度上，你们在重复他的心跳，说，是的，好吧，这是她在高中时爱上的那个男人。
This was her guy, this was her mountaintop guy.
这是她的男人，这是她的山顶男人。
And then to have him come in and just getting all, you know, scuffing him up and having years to.
然后让他进来并得到一切，你知道，把他弄坏并且有很多年的时间。
But what I love is he played it 100% like he was still that guy.
但我喜欢的是他百分百地打球，就像他还是那个人一样。
Yeah, with total confidence and swagger in this, but in this new body.
是的，在这个新的机构里，我充满信心和昂首阔步。
Yeah, he was still like the guy.
是的，他还是那个家伙。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was funny.
这很有趣。
Such a smart performance and, you know, he's, I remember laughing when he was doing it, but his, you know, demonstration of how he saves kids lives at the water park.
如此聪明的表演，你知道，他，我记得他在做这件事时笑了，但他，你知道，展示了他如何在水上公园拯救孩子们的生命。
So funny.
太有趣了。
And he's like kind of dismantling of Ted, like, Ted has just killed a bunch of kids.
他就像是对泰德的拆散，就像泰德刚刚杀了一群孩子一样。
And then kid just dad knows what's going on, he's killed a bunch of kids in this.
然后孩子爸爸就知道发生了什么事，他在这件事上杀了一群孩子。
Escalades very quickly, and that take down of 10.
升级速度非常快，并且减少了 10 个。
Yeah.
是的。
We could just meet James for that short clip here, 20 seconds of James Van to beat on the beach.
我们可以在这里与 James 见面，观看 James Van 在海滩上表演的 20 秒短片。
I'm playing Simon Tremblitt, former Canadian pop star from the 1980s, and flame for office workers.
我扮演西蒙·特伦布利特 (Simon Tremblitt)，他是 20 世纪 80 年代的前加拿大流行歌星，也是上班族的火焰。
1980s meant to me some really embarrassing fashions for Hairspray than any man should ever have in his head.
20 世纪 80 年代对我来说意味着发胶的一些非常尴尬的时尚，这是任何男人都不应该想到的。
Was it the night?
是晚上吗？
Oh, well, it was it's such a joke of like it was the 90s in Cal of the 90s.
哦，好吧，这真是一个笑话，就像是 90 年代加州的 90 年代一样。
The 90s didn't come to Canada until like 80 till 93 or whatever.
90 年代直到 80 年代到 93 年代才来到加拿大。
I'm but completely butchering it.
我只是彻底屠杀它。
But the 80s were on a table.
但80年代已经摆在桌面上了。
We're on a satellite delay in Canada says Robin and the first Robin sparkles.
罗宾说，我们在加拿大的卫星延误了，第一个罗宾闪闪发光。
Right.
正确的。
And it's true.
这是真的。
It's that's how we play it.
我们就是这样玩的。
Who knows if it's actually true Canadian friends, please reach out to us on the bike.
谁知道是不是真的加拿大朋友，请骑车联系我们。
Definitely a couple of our Canadians on staff are like, it's kind of true.
我们的一些加拿大员工肯定会说，这是真的。
But of course, we've just made that up.
但当然，我们刚刚弥补了这一点。
But James was still willing to look silly and be playful and ridiculous.
但詹姆斯还是​​愿意表现得傻傻的、俏皮可笑的。
And I think he really enjoyed playing against that heartthrob look.
我认为他真的很喜欢与那种万人迷的造型对抗。
And I think you do.
我想你会的。
I've heard you talk about this, Josh, just remember you've said it to me that you related to James, because you were Ted, right?
我听你谈论过这个，乔什，只要记住你对我说过你和詹姆斯有关系，因为你是特德，对吧？
You were defined as Ted Mosby.
你被定义为特德·莫斯比。
And like, people will yell that character name out to you on the street.
就像，人们会在街上向你喊出这个角色的名字。
And there's certain people who are like, He will always be that guy.
有些人会说，他永远是那个人。
I'm sure James spent so many years being like, I really enjoyed doing Dawson's Creek, but I'm not only that.
我确信詹姆斯多年来一直在说，我真的很喜欢做《道森溪》，但我不仅如此。
And I think that's why he was an immediate yes to like, yes, make me the pawn tree balding, but still ludicrously confident asshole boyfriend.
我想这就是为什么他立即同意喜欢，是的，让我成为当树秃顶，但仍然可笑地自信的混蛋男朋友。
I've never asked my younger sister, you know, what guest star she was probably most impressed I worked with or did the most kind of nostalgic thing to her, it would probably be James.
我从来没有问过我的妹妹，你知道，她对我合作过的客串明星印象最深刻，或者对她做过最怀旧的事情，可能就是詹姆斯。
Yeah, yeah, he was, he was beloved, um, such, such a sad loss, uh, RIP and our thoughts good.
是的，是的，他是，他是被爱着的，嗯，如此，如此悲伤的损失，呃，安息吧，我们的想法很好。
Everyone who, who knew and loved him, we were so lucky to get to work with him.
每个认识他、爱他的人，我们都很幸运能和他一起工作。
Yeah.
是的。
He was really a joy.
他真是一个快乐的人。
He was really a natural, he was a really strong comedic actor, I think.
我认为他真的是一个天生的喜剧演员。
You know, when he, he did more than just this comedically, but I mean, there's certain, um, like I would say that there's sweaty comedic actors and there's non sweaty comedic actors.
你知道，当他的时候，他所做的不仅仅是喜剧，但我的意思是，有一些，嗯，就像我会说的，有出汗的喜剧演员，也有不出汗的喜剧演员。
And I mean, this is the highest compliment.
我的意思是，这是最高的赞美。
Like, Will Forte is a sweaty comedic actor in that he's, you see him cranking up Martin Short.
就像威尔·福特是一位汗流浃背的喜剧演员，你可以看到他让马丁·肖特兴奋不已。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Yes, they're working.
是的，他们正在工作。
And you see the motor going and they're squeezing the laughs out of you and it's totally a pleasure.
你看到马达运转起来，他们让你大笑，这完全是一种乐趣。
Yeah.
是的。
And then there's other people like James's performance and this is very non sweaty.
还有其他人喜欢詹姆斯的表现，这非常不费力气。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Got a really tight touch with it.
与它的接触非常紧密。
He's throwing it away.
他正在把它扔掉。
He's really not underlining the comedy at all.
他真的根本没有强调喜剧。
He's just like, he's just playing a character and it's funny.
他就像，他只是在扮演一个角色，这很有趣。
It happens to be funny.
碰巧很有趣。
He let the balding wig in the pot belly do the work.
他让大腹便便的秃顶假发完成这项工作。
He didn't have to do much more.
他不需要做更多的事情。
He understood that the joke was same guy, different body.
他明白这个笑话是同一个人，不同的身体。
And he was great at it as the same guy.
他和同一个人一样擅长于此。
Yeah, he really understood.
是的，他确实明白了。
He hasn't changed at all.
他一点也没变。
And I love his sort of fake, compassionate voice where it's like, I'm like, ah, bam, I'm sorry, they put into Jacuzzi.
我喜欢他那种虚假的、富有同情心的声音，就像，我就像，啊，砰，对不起，他们放进了按摩浴缸。
My hands are tied.
我的手被绑住了。
Like I've got a breakup.
就像我分手了一样。
It's a Jacuzzi and it's like, you see what I'm working, you understand this.
这是一个按摩浴缸，就像，你看到我在做什么，你就明白了。
You see the position I'm in.
你看到我所处的位置了。
I have to go reunite with Louise Marsh if there's a Jacuzzi.
如果有按摩浴缸的话我必须去和路易丝·马什重聚。
You know what always is in those breakup scenes in the van is always the saddest part to me.
你知道在货车里的那些分手场景总是对我来说最悲伤的部分。
Is he waits for Robin to be done loading in the gear or he breaks up with her at both puns?
他是在等待罗宾装好装备，还是在这两个双关语中与她分手？
He knows he's breaking up with her.
他知道他要和她分手了。
He knows he's going to do that.
他知道他会这么做。
He's a narcissist, he was very funny in this, he was very funny in this.
他是个自恋者，他在这方面非常有趣，他在这方面非常有趣。
I wanted to bring up something that, because I've mentioned that there's a lot of interplay of in terms of attachment styles, which was not a term we were using back then, but you really see that Ted has this anxious attachment style, which means he overbonds to people kind of too quickly and he falls in love and he gets very scared that people are going to leave him, whereas Robin runs much more avoidant, same with Barney.
我想提出一些东西，因为我已经提到依恋风格之间有很多相互作用，这不是我们当时使用的术语，但你确实看到泰德有这种焦虑的依恋风格，这意味着他与人的关系太快了，他坠入爱河，他非常害怕人们会离开他，而罗宾则更加回避，巴尼也是如此。
They have this attacking style where they're underneath it, they're afraid of getting hurt, but they actually almost feel repelled by the anxious attaches.
他们有这种攻击风格，他们内心深处害怕受伤，但实际上他们几乎对焦虑的依恋感到排斥。
You're getting too close, you're moving too fast, put the brakes on.
你太近了，你开得太快了，踩刹车。
What happens to a lot of avoidant attaches is if they get swept up into a person who has another avoidant attachment, they will often turn anxious.
很多回避型依恋者会发生的情况是，如果他们被一个有另一种回避型依恋的人卷入其中，他们通常会变得焦虑。
Right.
正确的。
And we see that.
我们看到了这一点。
That's what happens here.
这就是这里发生的情况。
He's just like, hey, babe, he's the one who's way more avoidant, and it provokes this real sense of abandonment in her, and I'll do anything for this guy.
他就像，嘿，宝贝，他是那个更回避的人，这激起了她真正的被遗弃感，我会为这个家伙做任何事情。
Yeah, it's fascinating.
是的，这很有趣。
It's great to see the great thing about a long-running TV show is you just get to peel back the layers on these characters and just see this is who she was as a teenager.
很高兴看到一部长期播出的电视节目的伟大之处在于你可以剥开这些角色的层次，看到这就是她十几岁的样子。
this guy did this to her, she, her career as a pop star didn't work out, this guy dumped her, and she put on a new outfit after that, right?
这家伙对她做出这样的事，她，她的歌星事业没有成功，这家伙把她甩了，然后她就换上了新衣服是吧？
She put on this like really scotch and guns, and I'm gonna lean into kind of that sort of like masculine energy that her, you know, that her dad wanted her to be, which we dig into more in other flashbacks later.
她穿上这身衣服就像真正的苏格兰威士忌和枪支一样，我会倾向于那种男性能量，你知道，她父亲希望她成为这样的人，我们稍后会在其他闪回中深入探讨。
And I'm gonna come in and just be this like real badass, and to get to flashback in season three and see like this really vulnerable, even pathetic kind of, but heartbreaking side of her.
我会进来，就像真正的坏蛋一样，在第三季中闪回，看到她非常脆弱，甚至可怜，但令人心碎的一面。
It's such a fun, there's not too many other forms that allow that other than a long-running TV show where you just get to find these other chapters.
这太有趣了，除了长篇电视节目之外，没有太多其他形式可以让你找到这些其他章节。
You know, it just occurred to me, this is almost like a spiritual cousin of the first-season episode where you see Barney get hurt.
你知道，我刚刚想到，这几乎就像第一季中巴尼受伤的那一集的精神表亲。
Like an origin story.
就像一个起源故事。
It's like an origin story.
这就像一个起源故事。
This was heard suiting up at the end, you know, like putting out a different gel.
你知道，这在最后被听到了，就像推出了不同的凝胶一样。
I'm assuming that they both were like these incredible, they had their skins were very thin as young people.
我猜想他们俩都太不可思议了，他们年轻时脸皮都非常薄。
Yeah.
是的。
And they loved hard.
他们爱得很努力。
Yes.
是的。
And they loved fast.
他们爱得很快。
And they threw them in.
他们把它们扔了进去。
It's really true.
这是真的。
They both got.
他们都得到了。
Hippy Barney is the same as this problem with Simon.
嬉皮巴尼和西蒙的这个问题是一样的。
Yes.
是的。
And they both put on their armor.
然后两人都穿上了铠甲。
They both put on their costumes of impenetrability and toughness as they defined it.
他们都穿上了他们所定义的坚不可摧和坚韧的服装。
Yeah.
是的。
And that's why it's fitting that this is the episode where they kiss and it sets up the new huge conflict for the end of this whole season between Ted and Barney.
这就是为什么他们在这一集接吻并为泰德和巴尼之间整个季末带来新的巨大冲突是很合适的。
But they connect over this.
但他们通过这个联系起来。
You're right.
你说得对。
He is the one, Barney is the one who understands this situation enough to be the one to catch her.
他是那个人，巴尼是那个足够了解这种情况并能够抓住她的人。
Yeah.
是的。
He really sees it.
他确实看到了。
think he I think it's because of who he was at one point and you know and she has seen a glimpse of that in that episode that's a great observation I didn't even think of it that way but it really tracks the miss lead around you know when when he comes back to her apartment she says you know you really want to do this should I just put it in it's really funny it works it works it's it's really good it's old tech it's a VHS tape but that's on purpose.
我认为他是因为他曾经是谁，你知道，她在那一集中看到了这一点，这是一个很好的观察，我什至没有这么想，但它确实追踪了周围的小姐线索，当他回到她的公寓时，她说你知道你真的想这样做，应该我把它放进去，这真的很有趣，它有效，它有效，它真的很好，它是旧技术，它是一盘 VHS 磁带，但这是故意的。
That's good of a appropriate old tech.
这是一项合适的旧技术。
Well, you could only do that with old tech.
好吧，你只能用旧技术来做到这一点。
Yes, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
There's no, yeah, you can't be like, should we stream it?
不，是的，你不能说，我们应该直播吗？
No, that's disturbing.
不，这令人不安。
But yeah, I want to talk about the song for a second, the same castle song itself.
但是，是的，我想谈谈这首歌，同样的城堡歌曲本身。
And just say that big shout out to my then, you know, how old would my son have been?
然后对我大声喊叫，你知道，我儿子当时多大了？
My how old was my son Elliot have been at this?
我的儿子埃利奥特（Elliot）当时多大了？
Alec, what was the error date again?
Alec，错误日期又是哪一天？
Did you say this was he would have been one.
你说这就是他会是其中之一吗？
It's April 21st, 2008.
现在是 2008 年 4 月 21 日。
Okay, well, yes, once Elliot was born, it was very clear he was very, very musical.
好吧，嗯，是的，艾略特出生后，很明显他非常非常有音乐天赋。
Like he was, I think I've talked about this in the show.
就像他一样，我想我已经在节目中谈到了这一点。
He was in the neonatal intensive care unit for six weeks.
他在新生儿重症监护室呆了六周。
We sang to him because we couldn't hold him.
我们给他唱歌，因为我们无法抱住他。
He, you know, survived an open heart surgery.
你知道，他在一次心脏直视手术中幸存下来。
He got out and he got home.
他下了车就回家了。
And it was so clear that music was his thing.
很明显，音乐是他的专长。
Maybe in part because we had, that was our first way of communicating with him, but he's just naturally so musical.
也许部分是因为我们有过，这是我们与他交流的第一种方式，但他天生就是如此音乐。
So we do, we would write these songs for how much mother, Carter and I.
所以我们会为母亲、卡特和我写这些歌曲。
And ever since his birth and the realization in his early months, one year old, I would do a thing where if I was the guy originating the song, Carter and I co-wrote a lot of those songs, sometimes one of us did more than the other, but this was the one that I started off.
自从他出生并在他一岁时意识到这一点以来，我会做一件事，如果我是这首歌的创作者，卡特和我共同创作了很多这样的歌曲，有时我们中的一个人比另一个人做得更多，但这是我开始的。
And I sort of wrote a lot of music for in the melody and then we kind of wrote the lyrics together about some of the lyrics.
我在旋律中写了很多音乐，然后我们一起写了一些歌词。
And it really started with me sitting out of bed with the guitar, with Elliot, who was one.
这真的是从我和艾略特一起坐在床上弹吉他开始的，艾略特就是其中之一。
And he would reach out and strum at my guitar and like just he was fascinated by it.
他会伸出手来弹奏我的吉他，就像他被它迷住了一样。
And I had this really concrete and really lovely memory of knowing I had to write this song and just starting to like write melodies around him.
我有一个非常具体和非常可爱的记忆，知道我必须写这首歌，并且开始喜欢围绕他写旋律。
And the melody that made him smile was this one.
而让他微笑的旋律就是这首。
Wow.
哇。
And I would just absolutely let him decide which way I was gonna steer a lot of these songs that I, the ones that I originated the music for.
我绝对会让他决定我将如何引导我创作的许多歌曲。
And I just have such a clear memory of like, singing this melody to him and him smiling and me knowing this was it.
我有如此清晰的记忆，就像，给他唱这首歌，他微笑着，我知道就是这样。
This was, we were gonna build it all on this.
这是，我们要把这一切都建立在这个基础上。
And I would write this song and others just with him nearby to like let me know what was working.
我会和他一起写这首歌和其他歌曲，让我知道什么是有效的。
He was your radar for what was it?
他是你的雷达，因为什么？
He was my radar, yeah.
是的，他是我的雷达。
It was really cool.
真的很酷。
Yeah, and it's really, and I wrote the song.
是的，确实如此，这首歌是我写的。
He was a year old.
他一岁了。
We had been through so much.
我们经历了这么多。
He had been through, you know, so much medically and life or stuff.
你知道，他经历了太多的医疗、生活或其他事情。
And I remember like really pouring my heart into this absurd breakup song called, Cels is in the sand, like there is, this is not a bit, I am being in no way sarcastic or winky, there is legitimate heartfelt emotion in this song, like I really, I really feel something every time I hear it.
我记得我真的把我的心倾注在这首荒唐的分手歌曲中，《Cels is in the sand》，就像有的那样，这不是一点，我绝不是讽刺或眨眼，这首歌中有合法的发自内心的情感，就像我真的一样，每次听到它时我真的感受到了一些东西。
We play this song when you do our fundraiser concert for, you know, we do a How Much Mother Fundraiser concert in New York City every year, we always play the song.
当你举办我们的筹款音乐会时，我们会播放这首歌，你知道，我们每年在纽约市举办一场“How Much Mother 筹款音乐会”，我们总是播放这首歌。
It like, it legitimately moves me remembering how, like, much aching emotion I put into say.
它就像，它合理地让我想起我是如何投入的，就像，多么痛苦的情感。
Well, I think that's why, Craig, it has stood the test of time because Robin Sparkles and her team of, presumably, 20 of the best Canadian writers.
嗯，我想这就是为什么，克雷格，它经受住了时间的考验，因为罗宾·斯帕克尔斯和她的团队大概有 20 名加拿大最好的作家。
When they wrote this song, they were trying to go for something that would make teenage teenagers weep.
当他们写这首歌时，他们试图寻找一些能让十几岁的青少年哭泣的东西。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
And I, like, I remember, like, being near tears while working on this song, like moved to tears by, like how the heartache, I was putting my own like heartache into the song.
我，我记得，在创作这首歌时，我几乎要流泪了，就像感动得流泪，就像心痛一样，我把自己的心痛融入到了这首歌中。
And I would say, I would just give a shout out to one, there were so many, you know, listening to Debbie Gibson, listening to Tiffany, who was then in the video, Tiffany was a huge influence on the song.
我想说，我只想大声喊出一个，有很多人，你知道，听黛比·吉布森，听蒂芙尼，当时她在视频中，蒂芙尼对这首歌产生了巨大的影响。
But I would say the one that I wanted to give a shout out, like obviously the bangles, Blended Carlisle, all of that stuff, late 80s era.
但我想说的是我想大声喊出的那个，显然是手镯，混合卡莱尔，所有这些东西，80 年代末期。
And one that nobody talks about anymore that I really listened to, maybe the most while writing the song that I also find incredibly moving.
还有一首我真正听过的、再也没有人谈论的歌曲，也许是写这首歌时听得最多的一首，我也觉得这首歌非常感人。
So this day is the song, Toy Soldiers by Martika.
所以这一天是马蒂卡（Martika）的歌曲《玩具士兵》（Toy Soldiers）。
That I bet do you guys even know what I'm talking about?
我打赌你们知道我在说什么吗？
Do you mind to decide?
你介意决定吗？
I probably toy soldiers by Martika is fucking awesome.
我可能 Martika 的玩具士兵太棒了。
And it's like heartbreaking.
这就像令人心碎。
It's it's legitimately.
这是合法的。
It's a great song and it's really heartbreaking.
这是一首很棒的歌，而且真的很令人心碎。
It's more I think it's more about like drug.
我认为这更像是毒品。
There's like there's a hint of like drug use and like legitimate danger and addiction and it's not just a breakup.
好像有一些吸毒、合法危险和成瘾的暗示，而不仅仅是分手。
sides.
双方。
It's James Joyce Ian and it's layers, toy soldiers.
这是詹姆斯·乔伊斯·伊恩（James Joyce Ian）和它的分层，玩具士兵。
But that was a big one.
但那是一件大事。
I would listen that over and over and over while I was working on this song.
当我创作这首歌时，我会一遍又一遍地听这首歌。
And then Carter came in and we wrote so many lyrics together.
然后卡特进来了，我们一起写了很多歌词。
And, you know, it was just like, it was a really, it was a joy to work on this song.
而且，你知道，创作这首歌真的是一种乐趣。
But I would say that this is one of the most emotionally invested I was in any like song I ever wrote for how much mother.
但我想说，这是我为母亲写的任何类似歌曲中最投入情感的歌曲之一。
And I hope it comes across.
我希望它能够实现。
I think If you listen to that song, door to door, I think you can hear that in it a little bit.
我想如果你挨家挨户地听那首歌，我想你可以从里面听到一点。
And Kobe, when she performed it, she was going there.
而科比，当她表演的时候，她就要去那里。
Like she was, it's a, it's a sad breakup song.
就像她一样，这是一首悲伤的分手歌。
I'm very proud of how it kind of works on that, weirdly works on that level.
我对它在这方面的运作方式感到非常自豪，在这个层面上的运作方式很奇怪。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
这个老人，他一定要我说，爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials.
现在是广告。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
Craig, I'm curious as a songwriter on a show like this, so both for, let's go them all, and this song, the actual episode can't contain the whole song because you don't have enough time, obviously.
克雷格，作为这样的节目的词曲作者，我很好奇，所以无论是，让我们都去吧，这首歌，实际的剧集不能包含整首歌，因为你没有足够的时间，显然。
You're not gonna run a three, three and a half minute song.
你不会唱一首三、三分半钟的歌。
But you knew that somewhere would live, right?
但你知道某个地方会居住，对吗？
It would live somewhere and people would be able to watch it.
它会存在于某个地方，人们能够观看它。
But like, that must be a really interesting songwriting exercise to think about the economy.
但就像，这一定是一个非常有趣的歌曲创作练习来思考经济。
Which part am I gonna excerpt?
我要摘录哪一部分？
What am I going to see in this episode?
在这一集中我会看到什么？
What's the most important?
最重要的是什么？
What's the funniest, the most moving?
最搞笑、最感动的是什么？
Yeah, yeah, 100% with both of those.
是的，是的，这两点都是100%。
And it was painful because you knew there's going to be great things you can't see.
这很痛苦，因为你知道将会有一些你看不到的伟大事物。
So we always posted the full song online.
所以我们总是在网上发布完整的歌曲。
Obviously you can go on YouTube and look it up.
显然你可以去 YouTube 上查找。
The thing that we were so proud of these songs as full like three or four minute songs that we did that we did release.
我们对这些歌曲感到非常自豪，就像我们所做的三四分钟的歌曲一样，我们确实发行了。
And I'm still hearing from him and fans that don't know this exists.
我仍然收到他和粉丝的来信，他们不知道这件事的存在。
There's a double album of all the original music from how I met your mother, how I met your music volume one and two.
有一张双专辑，收录了《我如何遇见你母亲》、《我如何遇见你》音乐第一卷和第二卷的所有原创音乐。
And the two was like called Deluxe.
两者就像被称为豪华版。
And there are two full albums of all of these original songs.
所有这些原创歌曲都有两张完整专辑。
You can get them on all your streaming services.
您可以在所有流媒体服务上获取它们。
And yeah, people are still finding that to this day.
是的，直到今天人们仍在发现这一点。
It's great.
这很棒。
But we really wanted to compile it for exactly that reason, Josh.
但正是出于这个原因，我们真的很想编译它，乔什。
We're like, we can't just, these songs can't just go away.
我们想，我们不能，这些歌曲不能就这么消失。
You can't just have seen 45 seconds of one of these songs in one TV episode.
您不可能在一集电视剧中只看过其中一首 45 秒的歌曲。
We were too proud of them, especially when we shot a whole music video too.
我们为他们感到太自豪了，尤其是当我们也拍摄了整个音乐视频时。
Yeah.
是的。
Shout out to Ryan Bethe who was a first year at NYU when I was a third year.
向 Ryan Bethe 致敬，他是纽约大学的一年级学生，而我是第三年。
Awesome.
惊人的。
I didn't, I forgot that if I knew it.
我没有，如果我知道的话我就忘记了。
Yeah, I was a little NYU reunion on set, which was really fun.
是的，我在片场参加了一次纽约大学的聚会，这真的很有趣。
But I'm curious, like, I don't think the lily thing in her like plays particularly well these days, do you?
但我很好奇，我觉得她身上的百合花样现在表现得不太好，你觉得吗？
Yeah, I worry about it a little.
是的，我有点担心。
Because it's definitely built on a real thing, but then seeing it enacted, it's like, I could see this bothering some folks and I'm sorry if that's that's really definitely wasn't meant to be that.
因为它绝对是建立在真实的事情上的，但是当看到它被颁布时，就像，我可以看到这让一些人感到困扰，如果那真的绝对不是那样的，我很抱歉。
Yeah, so I didn't think it aged pretty well.
是的，所以我不认为它老化得很好。
I thought Ryan and Ali did it as well as they could have done, you know, but I just wanted to flag that.
我认为瑞安和阿里做得很好，你知道，但我只是想指出这一点。
I just wanted to go through a couple of things that I flagged that I thought were really funny and charming in this episode.
我只是想回顾一下我认为在这一集中非常有趣和迷人的几件事。
So I'm in smelling like Drakkar.
所以我闻起来像德拉卡。
Drakkar?
德拉卡？
See, that's like Courtney can't.
瞧，这就像考特尼做不到的那样。
That's what I mean.
这就是我的意思。
Like Courtney just went back and just had those details.
就像考特尼刚刚回去并了解了这些细节一样。
I guarantee you that's from her original script.
我向你保证那是她原来的剧本。
Drakkar, Drakkar is the perfect example of like what she has right on her fingertips to put in an episode like this.
Drakkar，Drakkar 就是一个完美的例子，她可以轻松地在这样的剧集中添加内容。
But also like, I don't know a single dude in that era who wasn't wearing Drakkar.
但同时，我不知道那个时代有哪个男人不穿 Drakkar。
Drakkar, it was a thing.
德拉卡，这是一件事。
Early 90s, Alec, you raised your hand.
90 年代初，亚历克，你举起了手。
You were four in Drakkar.
你在德拉卡时才四岁。
I mean, I wish I'd known you then.
我是说，我希望那时就认识你。
Everyone was a fan, hard rock, cafe, t-shirts, also a huge thing.
每个人都是粉丝，硬摇滚、咖啡馆、T 恤，也是一件大事。
Huge thing, yep.
很大的事情，是的。
These were all just corny details from her first draft, I guarantee it.
我保证，这些都只是她初稿中的陈词滥调细节。
She didn't have to change any of that.
她不需要改变这一切。
It was like, perfect, absolutely perfect reference.
这就像，完美​​，绝对完美的参考。
I always, this happens a lot in the show where you, it's like the cast becomes the writer's room where they're just like, we're sitting around, we're splitting a picture and we're going to come up with 800 Canadian jokes.
我总是，这种情况在节目中经常发生，就像演员们变成了编剧的房间，他们坐在一起，我们正在分割一张照片，然后我们将想出 800 个加拿大笑话。
I think we, maybe we own that form.
我想我们，也许我们拥有这种形式。
You know that fast forward and pop out to hear one thing and then fast-forwarding and pop it in here one thing.
您知道快进并弹出来听到一件事，然后快进并在这里弹出一件事。
We do it a lot alone.
我们独自做很多事情。
We run it another ground a little bit, we did it a lot.
我们又做了一点，我们做了很多次。
But I think that's our, I really am proud of that joke.
但我认为那是我们的，我真的为这个笑话感到自豪。
And I feel like Chris Harris was always a good pit, either he came up with that form or he just was good at pitching on the form.
我觉得克里斯·哈里斯总是一个很好的坑，要么他想出了那种形式，要么他只是擅长在这种形式上投球。
Just that idea of you just get these little glimpses.
只是你的想法只是瞥见了这些小小的一瞥。
I think, I'm very proud whenever we get to that.
我想，每当我们做到这一点时，我都会感到非常自豪。
Cause I'm like, I don't see that joke a lot of other places.
因为我想，我在其他很多地方都看不到这个笑话。
So the fast forward through three hour conversation.
快进到三个小时的谈话。
There's something about, let's say a 22 minute show, even in our long show, where you're only showing the most important bits, right?
比如说一个 22 分钟的节目，即使在我们的长节目中，你也只展示最重要的部分，对吧？
The most important bits.
最重要的部分。
But the truth of hanging out with your friends in a bar all the time, is there a lot of stretches.
但一直和朋友在酒吧闲逛的真相是，有很多伸展运动。
It's a volume business.
这是一项批量业务。
You're just firing jokes.
你只是开个玩笑而已。
You're just saying stupid stuff.
你只是在说些蠢话。
They're not all winners.
他们并不都是赢家。
They're not all winners, but also like a lot of shows don't dip into that aspect of the hang, which is let's try to make each other laugh.
他们并不都是赢家，但也像很多节目一样，不会涉及到这个方面，那就是让我们试着让彼此发笑。
And I think that's, again, part of the kind of unconscious fabric of the show that people love and feel great warmth towards is you get the feeling of hanging out with your friends in a bar.
我认为，这又是该剧无意识结构的一部分，人们喜欢并感到非常温暖，因为你会得到与朋友在酒吧闲逛的感觉。
Like you go short circuit or try to act like there aren't moments of like, wow, we've had too many.
就像你会短路或试图表现得好像没有这样的时刻，哇，我们已经经历了太多。
Should we get another, okay, let's get another one.
如果我们再买一个，好吧，我们再买一个。
Or it just, in a very clever way, it gives the texture of life.
或者它只是以一种非常聪明的方式赋予了生活的质感。
Yeah, because you look back and you're like, remember that night we were making that stupid joke all night and like sometimes it was funny that it stopped being funny, then it got funny again.
是的，因为你回头看，你会想，记得那天晚上我们整晚都在讲那个愚蠢的笑话，有时很有趣，它不再有趣了，然后又变得有趣了。
It's such a, that is the nature of having a friend group.
这就是朋友圈的本质。
And it's, I think we, I like to think we capture that without form of the fast forward.
我想我们，我喜欢认为我们在没有快进形式的情况下捕捉到了这一点。
But I don't know any other show that really has gone into that particular thing, which is like sometimes you're just sitting around and trying to come up with the funniest version of the joke.
但我不知道有任何其他节目真正涉及到这个特定的事情，就像有时你只是坐在那里试图想出这个笑话的最有趣的版本。
Yeah, and it really is like, if you had fast forward on a writer's room, that's what it would be like.
是的，确实就像，如果你在作家的房间里快进，那就会是这样。
Like, Jesus Christ, we all pitched for two hours on that stupid thing, and there was like four good jokes in there.
就像，天啊，我们都在这个愚蠢的事情上花了两个小时，里面有四个好笑话。
Those moments to me are like, if you wanna know what a comedy writer's room is like.
对我来说，那些时刻就像，如果你想知道喜剧作家的房间是什么样的。
That's it.
就是这样。
Those on TV, the clearest idea.
电视上的那些，最清楚的想法。
It is very meta, it is a very meta thing.
这是非常元的，这是非常元的事情。
And I really enjoy that, cause that kind of starts the episode, and then it goes into the next kind of joke form that it does is also a great hymium one, which is the jumping ahead and then doing the autopsy of what happened in flashback.
我真的很喜欢这一点，因为这种方式开始了这一集，然后它进入了下一种笑话形式，它也是一个很棒的欢乐形式，那就是向前跳跃，然后对闪回中发生的事情进行尸检。
Everyone gets back to the apartment and they're like, Robin, we have to talk about what we all just witnessed at the bar and you can cherry pick the best moments of that.
每个人都回到公寓，他们说，罗宾，我们必须谈谈我们刚刚在酒吧目睹的事情，你可以挑选其中最好的时刻。
And it becomes this greatest hits kind of feeling.
这变成了这种最热门的感觉。
It's like this greatest hits album of like, here's the important parts.
就像这张精选专辑一样，这里是重要的部分。
And they all sat there watching her be so pitiful to Simon and they can kind of comment from the future and you get to tee things up and pay them off.
他们都坐在那里看着她对西蒙如此可怜，他们可以从未来发表评论，你可以把事情做好并付清代价。
That is also a very hymium-y form.
这也是一种非常 hymium 的形式。
So there were two very like banger-hymium form is kind of right on top of each other.
因此，有两种非常相似的 banger-hymium 形式，就在彼此之上。
And that's a really unique thing because you are, the way our memory works is like we tend to remember the more dramatic bursts of things.
这是一件非常独特的事情，因为我们的记忆工作方式就像我们倾向于记住更戏剧性的事情爆发一样。
Yeah.
是的。
And a lot fades into the background.
很多东西都消失在背景中。
I mean, again, it's like a show about memory, but there are memories within memories within memories.
我的意思是，这就像一部关于记忆的节目，但记忆中的记忆中还有记忆。
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
是的，是的，完全正确。
Exactly.
确切地。
It's this Russian nesting doll of memory and kind of analysis.
这是俄罗斯套娃的记忆和分析。
I love like Crash Test Dummy's big, Crash Test Dummy's big.
我喜欢碰撞测试假人的大，碰撞测试假人的大。
There are four or five gigs away from exploding, which is amazing.
还有四五场演出就将爆发，这真是太神奇了。
I also loved Maple Leaf on the back of the truck, Red Province, he's from the North.
我也喜欢卡车后面的枫叶，红省，他来自北方。
He's from the deep North, just like you know the type.
他来自北方深处，就像你所知道的那样。
I'm like Canada is like the US, but it's like Bizarro US.
我觉得加拿大就像美国，但又像奇怪的美国。
Yeah, just goes, just the Enrichs, this kind of mirror image to the North.
是的，就这样，只是Enrichs，这种北方的镜像。
Yeah.
是的。
But I also love, I just wanna give another shout out to Murder Train, the song by the foreskin's Murder Train.
但我也喜欢，我只是想再次大声喊出《谋杀列车》，这是包皮乐队的《谋杀列车》的歌曲。
I will say that was really a huge shout out to John Swahart, our composer, Brian Kim is a co-composer of the show too.
我想说，这对我们的作曲家约翰·斯瓦哈特（John Swahart）来说确实是一个巨大的欢呼，布莱恩·金（Brian Kim）也是该节目的联合作曲家。
But the reason I'm singling out Swahart on this one, he was our main composer, but that's his voice.
但我之所以在这首歌曲中单独提到斯瓦哈特，是因为他是我们的主要作曲家，但这就是他的声音。
That's him singing Murder Train.
那是他唱的《谋杀列车》。
He was a legitimate shredding heavy metal guitar player.
他是一位真正的重金属吉他手。
He's a beautiful composer and all the score on him, that you hear so much of it is him doing this beautiful, very sensitive work.
他是一位出色的作曲家，所有的配乐都在他身上，你听到的很多都是他在创作这部美丽、非常敏感的作品。
But in his river to go, and Sean Swagites river to go, you would see a very heavy metal like crazy late 80s, early 90s kind of version of Swagart at some point, who was this really sweet dude, and he was just a guy with kids and a lovely like, but he definitely like, when he, we said, can you do like kind of a heavy metal, like this song called Murder Shran, he's like, I got it.
但在他的 River to go 和 Sean Swagites 的 River to go 中，你会看到一种非常重金属，就像疯狂的 80 年代末、90 年代初版本的 Swagat，他是一个非常可爱的家伙，他只是一个有孩子和可爱的人，但他绝对喜欢，当我们说，你能像那种重金属一样，就像这首歌叫做 Murder Shran 一样，他就像，我明白了。
Oh, I was in this band, you have no problem.
哦，我是这个乐队的，你没问题。
Tearing the guitars down to D or whatever that he like knew exactly what to do He knew how to do that voice at the game Maybe was has sang and bands like that before he's he's a shredding kick-ass guitar player So I heard and so that I just big shout out on murder train and the murder train on the adopt the puppies thing is Is another just gem for me.
把吉他撕成D或任何他喜欢的东西知道该怎么做他知道如何在游戏中发出那种声音也许在他之前他就已经唱歌和乐队了，他是一个撕碎的强大吉他手所以我听到了，所以我只是在谋杀列车上大喊大叫，而谋杀列车上收养小狗的事情对我来说是另一颗宝石。
It just ever that makes me laugh every single time They got so many puppies adopted because they thought they were gonna kill them.
每次他们收养这么多小狗时，我都会笑，因为他们认为他们会杀死它们。
It definitely seems like they're gonna kill them at a hundred percent does name of the band is for skins.
看起来他们肯定会百分百地杀死他们，因为乐队的名字是为了皮肤。
And the reason is there's four of us and we play without shirts.
原因是我们有四个人，而且我们比赛时不穿球衣。
Yes.
是的。
And you can't believe Ted didn't understand that.
你无法相信特德不明白这一点。
He's like, babe, who is this guy?
他说，宝贝，这家伙是谁？
How does this guy not get this?
这家伙怎么就不懂呢？
And he's Ted's an idiot.
他是特德，是个白痴。
Ted doesn't know how to protect children on the waterslide.
特德不知道如何在滑水道上保护儿童。
And he doesn't understand the cleverness of the foreskin's name.
而且他也不明白包皮这个名字的巧妙之处。
It's really funny.
真的很有趣。
And I would say murder train, like, that was when I also where we gave it to John so I heard like, we don't have music for this.
我会说谋杀列车，就像那时我也把它给了约翰所以我听说，我们没有这方面的音乐。
We don't know what this is.
我们不知道这是什么。
It's called murder train.
这就是所谓的谋杀列车。
It's It's going to be over some kittens and he was just so he really I said Carter and I write a lot of the original stuff But that's that's really a swy heart special in a lot of ways.
这将是一些小猫的事情，他只是这样，他真的我说卡特和我写了很多原创的东西，但这在很多方面确实是一颗摇摆不定的心。
Yeah This is he intro punchy, right?
是的，这就是他的介绍，对吧？
Yeah, this is meeting how we met punchy, right?
是的，这就是我们见面的方式，对吧？
I believe this is the Chris Romano really funny dude who later wrote for him Yeah, later in the series and he just he had these really funny like internet videos that Carter and I were fans of and like he We just we thought it was funny.
我相信这是克里斯·罗马诺（Chris Romano）非常有趣的家伙，后来为他写了是的，在该系列的后面，他只是他有这些非常有趣的网络视频，卡特和我都是粉丝，就像他一样，我们只是认为这很有趣。
We just thought there was something so like he's just that guy He really has that shitbuster shitbuster.
我们只是觉得他就是那个家伙，他真的有那个垃圾克星。
He had this really go look up Chris Romano shitbuster from like the early 2000s It's really funny and I'll tell you in a later episode, but I remember he wrote on the Sarah Silverman show right I think yeah, I think so and I can't tell the actual stories because they're actually too Strange and filthy, but I knew you know So I know Sarah, and I said, oh, Chris, Chris, Ramonski, or it wasn't, was he going by Ramonski?
他真的去查了一下2000年代初的克里斯·罗马诺（Chris Romano）的狗屎克星，这真的很有趣，我会在稍后的剧集中告诉你，但我记得他在莎拉·西尔弗曼（Sarah Silverman）节目中写道，我想是的，我想是的，我无法讲述实际的故事，因为它们实际上太奇怪和肮脏，但我知道你知道所以我认识莎拉，我说，哦，克里斯，克里斯，拉蒙斯基，或者不是，他是不是经过拉蒙斯基？
His Chris Ramano and his, his one name, Tiffany, ask name for himself was Ramonski.
他的克里斯·拉马诺（Chris Ramano）和他的名字蒂芙尼（Tiffany）是拉蒙斯基（Ramonski）。
Ramonski.
拉蒙斯基.
He also went by one name for a while.
有一段时间他也只用过一个名字。
So I texted Sarah, and I said, Ramonski is on our show.
所以我给莎拉发短信，我说，拉蒙斯基在我们的节目中。
And she said, ask him to tell the bean bag story and the CDs.
她说，请他讲一下豆袋故事和 CD。
That's all I'll say right now.
我现在要说的就是这些。
Okay, that's the you're planning a scene for future stories.
好吧，这就是你为未来故事规划的场景。
Okay.
好的。
We'll get there.
我们会到达那里。
Okay.
好的。
He told me these stories and I think it was the hardest I laughed on how I'm gonna mother sat.
他给我讲了这些故事，我想这是我对妈妈的坐姿笑得最厉害的一次。
He has stories.
他有故事。
He's a character.
他是一个人物。
He's got a lot of nudity in his life.
他的生活中有很多裸体。
That's all I said.
我就说了这么多。
There's a lot of nudity there as they say NSFW.
正如他们所说，那里有很多裸体内容 NSFW。
I think that is very safe to say that.
我认为这样说是非常有把握的。
But it was so funny.
但这太有趣了。
So yeah, so this is the introduction of punchy who obviously comes back.
是的，这就是对显然回来了的Punchy的介绍。
It really makes, he really makes me laugh when you realize his dad passed away.
当你意识到他父亲去世时，他真的让我发笑。
And it's really, yeah, it really came as a shock.
确实，是的，这确实令人震惊。
They're right about to wrestle and then they stop to mourn punchy's dad.
他们正要摔跤，然后停下来哀悼潘奇的父亲。
It's just, it's, that is a great flashback.
只是，这是，那是一个很棒的闪回。
It's really, yeah.
确实是这样啊
Chris also has like a kind of gravelly, I don't know, like hometown bro voice that's very funny.
克里斯还有一种沙哑的，我不知道，像家乡兄弟的声音，非常有趣。
Very authentic.
非常正宗。
You can really picture him and Ted just being jackasses as kids.
你真的可以想象他和特德小时候都是傻瓜。
For a minute, Carter and I wanted to do like a spin-off animated show that was like Ted and Punchy in the 1990s in Cleveland.
有一段时间，卡特和我想做一个衍生动画节目，就像 20 世纪 90 年代克利夫兰的《Ted and Punchy》一样。
What are you telling me?
你在告诉我什么？
Yeah.
是的。
We could still do that.
我们仍然可以这样做。
We could.
我们可以。
I think that'd be really funny because the 90s are obviously back.
我认为这真的很有趣，因为 90 年代显然又回来了。
Yeah.
是的。
No, I legitimately think it could be a thing.
不，我有理由认为这可能是一件事。
We had ideas for it and stuff.
我们对此有一些想法。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
Let's talk about that often.
让我们经常谈论这一点。
Lillian Marshall as Robin's parents is really funny that bit cracks me up so hard every time everybody is killing it in that bit I remembered and I don't know if I just did this instinctively or if some Pam told me to but Ted just starts playing the younger brother Yeah, he's he wants some attention.
莉莲·马歇尔饰演罗宾的父母真的很有趣，每次每个人都在我记得的那段杀戮中，这让我很开心，我不知道我是否只是本能地这样做，或者如果一些帕姆告诉我这样做，但泰德刚刚开始扮演弟弟是的，他是他想要一些关注。
He's like, okay.
他就像，好吧。
My here's my day.
这是我的一天。
Oh my sister's in trouble like his body the foster.
哦，我的妹妹遇到了麻烦，就像他的寄养者的身体一样。
It's really funny.
真的很有趣。
We were in love once too young lady.
我们也曾经相爱过，年轻的女士。
He had like a billion years ago.
他大概是十亿年前的事了。
Yeah.
是的。
And no, the scene with, there's two scenes obviously, but the scene with Robin and Barney at the bar, I thought, you know, it's a classic how I make your mother think to have a, you know, a pretty broad episode that's like got all the hymnium kind of stuff in it.
不，显然有两个场景，但是罗宾和巴尼在酒吧的场景，我想，你知道，这是一个经典，我如何让你妈妈认为有一个，你知道，一个相当广泛的情节，就像里面有所有赞美诗之类的东西。
And it's normally, you would give it, you know, early seasons are a lot of Ted and Robin.
通常情况下，你会知道，前几季有很多泰德和罗宾。
There needs to be a name for it, like the act five sincere scene or something, you know what I mean?
需要给它起一个名字，比如第五幕真诚的场景之类的，你知道我的意思吗？
Well, towards the end, it's always like, it's Robin and Ted on the balcony and sledding pumpkin on the top of the roof.
好吧，到最后，总是这样，罗宾和泰德在阳台上，在屋顶上滑着南瓜雪橇。
We do it a lot.
我们经常这样做。
This one goes to Robin and Barney.
这是送给罗宾和巴尼的。
And I was really moved by both of their takes, right?
他们的两个表演都让我很感动，对吧？
Her take is aging, like, I'm sad, I'm not that girl, I'm sad, I'm not that vulnerable.
她的看法是衰老，就像，我很伤心，我不是那个女孩，我很伤心，我没那么脆弱。
Like, she has like nostalgia for her young herself in a weird way.
就像，她以一种奇怪的方式怀念年轻时的自己。
Yes.
是的。
And Barney's take is actually like a really good friend take.
巴尼的看法实际上就像一个非常好的朋友的看法。
It's like, you're so much cooler now.
就好像，你现在酷多了。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, that's sweet.
是的，那很甜蜜。
It's ridiculous.
这太荒谬了。
Like this girl now, this woman now is way cooler than that person.
就像现在这个女孩一样，这个女人现在比那个人酷多了。
Yeah, and his premise of I'm gonna show you, I want to remind you how stupid that past version of yourself was to let you know how awesome you are now.
是的，他的前提是我要告诉你，我想提醒你过去的自己是多么愚蠢，让你知道你现在有多棒。
And that's what she needs to hear.
这就是她需要听到的。
And he gets it.
他明白了。
He gets it because he also lived that.
他明白这一点，因为他也经历过这样的事情。
There's a past version of himself, heartbroken by Shannon, who he was the lap dog for, just like she was with them.
他有一个过去的版本，被香农伤心欲绝，他是香农的哈巴狗，就像香农和他们在一起一样。
And it's a really, this was a good moment to have them kiss.
这确实是他们接吻的好时机。
This was a good moment for that.
这是一个很好的时刻。
But it was also like, I like that it honors both of those points of view, because they're both very how I met your mother, which is we're aging, you know, it's like the land slide line that is the crusher, you know, I'm getting old, you know, I'm getting older too, like.
但它也就像，我喜欢它尊重这两种观点，因为它们都是我遇见你母亲的方式，那就是我们正在变老，你知道，就像是破碎机的土地滑坡线，你知道，我正在变老，你知道，我也在变老，就像。
Yeah, it's just a crusher.
是的，这只是一个破碎机。
And in movies when you, you know, they jump forward 25 years and characters have gray hair, probably people see my gray hair when they tune into there, they're like, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, that aging is both harrowing and sad and poignant, and also you wouldn't want to go back to yesterday if you're honest with yourself.
在电影中，当你，你知道，他们跳跃了 25 年，角色有白发，可能人们在观看时看到我的白发，他们就像，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，衰老既令人痛苦又悲伤又令人心酸，而且如果你对自己诚实，你也不会想回到昨天。
Yeah, well said.
是啊，说得好。
So I think that there's something about these points of view where he says like, you know, this is a thing I have, like a beef I have with America, one of the few, but it's like younger equals better.
所以我认为他的这些观点是有道理的，你知道，这是我拥有的东西，就像我与美国的牛肉一样，是为数不多的牛肉之一，但似乎年轻就等于更好。
Yeah.
是的。
It's like a real lie.
这就像一个真正的谎言。
It's a real cultural lie, we tell ourselves.
我们告诉自己，这是一个真正的文化谎言。
And I like that Barney says, like you've gotten better.
我喜欢巴尼说的，就像你变得更好了一样。
You're better now, like a whiskey that they both like to drink, you know, like you're aging well.
你现在好多了，就像他们都喜欢喝的威士忌一样，你知道，就像你变老了一样。
And I think that's a nice thing for friends to reflect back to each other.
我认为朋友之间互相反思是件好事。
Yeah, he really loves her.
是的，他真的很爱她。
He's really like, he loves her as a friend.
他真的很喜欢她，就像朋友一样。
and the way they play that scene when they're at the bar and it's a mislead, you think they're gonna kiss, you're gonna hook up and then it's like a double mislead.
当他们在酒吧时，他们演那个场景的方式是一种误导，你认为他们会接吻，你会勾搭，然后这就像是双重误导。
The mislead is nailed, they're just gonna watch the video.
误导已被消除，他们只会看视频。
Then the double mislead is, yes, they are gonna hook up in this episode, but I thought Barney played it really tenderly, like the way he's looking and Neil played that really well, that scene in that bar.
然后双重误导是，是的，他们会在这一集里勾搭上，但我认为巴尼演得很温柔，就像他看起来的样子，而尼尔演得很好，那个酒吧的场景。
He's really, you see his love for her in that moment and it's really nice.
他真的，在那一刻你看到他对她的爱，这真的很好。
And you also see that Robin pulls a kind of tenderness tenderness out of Barney that no one else can do.
你还会看到罗宾从巴尼身上汲取了一种其他人无法做到的温柔。
Yeah, I think because they see each other's wounds in a really like in an accurate way that maybe other people can't see.
是的，我想是因为他们以一种非常相似的方式准确地看到彼此的伤口，而其他人可能看不到。
And they were they have a similar trajectory.
他们有相似的轨迹。
They both kind of suited up.
他们俩都很合身。
They both kind of covered over like cemented over who they used to be and made this new thing and yeah.
他们都覆盖了自己，就像巩固了自己曾经的样子，创造了这个新事物，是的。
And you guys do another really, I think, death, how I made another thing.
我想，你们真的做了另一件事，死亡，我是如何创造另一件事的。
This could be a bottle episode.
这可能是一个瓶子事件。
Like you could and just enjoy this.
就像你可以并且享受这个一样。
but Robin and Barney, at the end, really moves the chest beat forward.
但罗宾和巴尼最后确实把胸部向前推进了。
And in fact, it's in to overdrive the rest of the plot for the rest of the season.
事实上，它会超载本季余下的情节。
I've said this in this kind of back nine of the season, how it was, we were the writer's guild strike happened, and then it ended in the last two months, it ended and we had to make these like last nine episodes of season three really, really quickly.
我已经在本季的后九集里说过了，事情是怎样的，我们发生了编剧工会罢工，然后它在最后两个月结束了，它结束了，我们必须非常非常快地制作这些，就像第三季的最后九集一样。
And the underthinking, and I mean that in a good way, the lack of overthinking, it was so great because you might think to yourself, season three, I don't know, it's a little too early to have to do that, right?
还有思考不足，我的意思是，从一个好的方面来说，没有过度思考，这太棒了，因为你可能会想，第三季，我不知道，现在这样做有点太早了，对吧？
Robin and Ted were a thing, is this too soon?
罗宾和泰德是一回事，这是否太早了？
We're like, no, we need material.
我们说，不，我们需要材料。
We need rocket fuel.
我们需要火箭燃料。
We got every episode has to end with something that gives you something to talk about in the next, and this gives this moment of them kissing at the end, defines the last few episodes of season three that come.
我们知道每一集都必须以一些让你在下一集有话可说的东西结束，这给了他们在最后接吻的时刻，定义了即将到来的第三季的最后几集。
I'm so glad we did it.
我很高兴我们做到了。
We probably could have talked ourselves out of it, but it gave us a really, it gave us this kind of like propulsion out into outer space of these last few episodes and it's exciting.
我们可能可以说服自己放弃它，但它给了我们一种真正的，它给了我们这种最后几集的外太空推进力，这很令人兴奋。
These next few episodes that happen are really great ones.
接下来发生的几集真的很棒。
So we'll, to begin with Will Forte, he's coming up.
所以我们首先请威尔·福特（Will Forte），他即将上场。
10 Barney friendship breakup, Will Forte rebound, bro.
10 巴尼友谊破裂，威尔·福特反弹，兄弟。
All this great stuff reunion at the end of the season.
所有这些伟大的东西在赛季结束时重聚。
It all happened because you're right.
这一切都发生了，因为你是对的。
We didn't just make a little battle episode.
我们不只是制作了一小段战斗情节。
We said, this is a cliffhanger episode.
我们说，这是一个扣人心弦的情节。
And it's really, it sneaks up on you at the end.
确实，它最后会悄悄出现在你身上。
This episode does a lot in 21 minutes and 50 seconds.
这一集在 21 分 50 秒内发生了很多事情。
I gotta say, this is one that I am proud of looking back.
我得说，这是我回顾过去感到自豪的一件事。
It's like there's not, it's all killer and no filler this episode.
好像没有，这一集都是杀手，没有填充物。
Like, there's like a lot going on in a short period of time and that's what makes a good hymnion.
就像，短时间内发生了很多事情，这就是一首好的赞美诗。
You know what my favorite part of the song is?
你知道这首歌里我最喜欢的部分是什么吗？
Shut up.
住口。
Ha ha ha.
哈哈哈。
Ha ha ha ha.
哈哈哈哈。
There's lots of friends, just shut up.
有很多朋友，就闭嘴吧。
All right.
好的。
Nice to shut up, and now thanks for joining us.
很高兴闭嘴，现在感谢您加入我们。
Shut up.
住口。
We had a great time talking about this episode.
我们很高兴谈论这一集。
Great to see you, Craig.
很高兴见到你，克雷格。
Great to see you, Alec.
很高兴见到你，亚历克。
If you would like to write us a note, send us a voice note.
如果您想给我们留言，请向我们发送语音留言。
but maybe we'll read it or play it on the show.
但也许我们会读它或在节目中播放它。
Go to h-w-m-y-m, how we made your mother.com.
访问 h-w-m-y-m，了解我们如何创建 your mother.com。
Go to contact, follow the interactions.
去联系，关注互动。
We'd love to hear from you.
我们很乐意听取您的意见。
And we'll see you next time.
我们下次再见。
Thanks so much.
非常感谢。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
In New York City.
在纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
And it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
它由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 提供和分发。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Madica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马迪卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves（blue studio 的一名成员），我们的 Gen Z Masters（我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg）和副制作人 Katherine Grove（凯瑟琳·格罗夫）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作，无论在哪里出售书籍，事情都不是这样发生的，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own dead father's society on Substack.
你可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。